thank you very very much for coming to
this very unusual occasion to have dr.
Samantha power currently special
assistant to President Barack Obama here
the occasion is the vera and Donald
Lincoln lecture which has been held
pretty much annually over the last
several years and which brings to
columbia university distinguished
practitioners States people who also
have an interest in European affairs and
in that framework we've had Thomas
Pickering holbrook senator Biden when he
was in senator Lord Patten Christopher
patent former governor of Hong Kong and
last year Nicholas Burns just after he
retired from this state department so
it's a wonderful sequence of people and
tonight somebody quite quite new to all
of this Samantha power so let me just
introduce Sam Samantha power she special
assistant she runs the office of
multilateral affairs and human rights in
the National Security Council and she's
also a professor of practice the
annalynne professor of practice of
global leadership and public policy at
Harvard's Kennedy School of Government
and that that's if you want just the
most recent accomplishments let's go
back somewhat further Samantha power is
born in Ireland and grew up in the US
and was educated at Yale and at Harvard
Law School and early she worked as a
journalist covering some of the most
difficult Wars Bosnia and civil war in
Rwanda writing for various publications
in the United States and elsewhere and
on the basis of that work that she
partook in the myriad debates arising in
the 1980s and 90s over the meaning of
humanitarian intervention in her book
which won the Pulitzer Prize in 2003
problem from hell American the age of
genocide she criticized strong with the
Clinton administration for its failures
of Bosnian Wanda and urged the United
States and develop a new calculus in
foreign policy very different from the
old realism but also from the new
realism which could be the new realism
meaning you could do nothing or yuh'll
addley send in the Marines working with
the its allies and international
organizations the Americas a leadership
in her view had to ratchet up its
international engagement commensurate
with abuses on the ground this book was
a canonical text for students here and
human rights at Columbia but has also
been very much debated subsequently she
strongly opposed the war in iraq as
unilateral and not dictated by the
interest of the iraqi people's welfare
and out of the iraq war came her
extraordinary next book chasing the
flame about the Brazilian diplomat and
passionate Sergio Vieira de Mello who
died in the explosion of the UN Center
in Baghdad hey and that too was a
reflection in many ways about an
extraordinary beautiful and capable man
on a mission but also on the u.s. UN's
humanitarian and state building
capacities now after working for the
Obama campaign in 2008 Samantha power
has become an advisor to the president
one of his closest advisors in the very
fraught moment I should just say by way
of conclusion before introducing briefly
Donald blinken whose whose name is
lecture has been founded you don't get
Samantha power by simply saying oh
hey come on up we're at Columbia we're
waiting for you we asked her at least a
year ago not knowing all that would be
coming about we recognized her in her a
new kind of statesman or i should say
states woman or states person state
person a pasta idea who subscribes to
the words of advice she gave at one
point graduating students at Santa Clara
law school let's reason be your tool but
let justice be your cause before
Samantha speaks let me introduce Donald
blinken who with his wife veera former
ambassadors to Hungary the educator
benefactor of the European Institute
here at Columbia University and he will
want to say a couple of words
thank you very much Vicki that was a
very very succinctly to the point I want
to congratulate you on organizing this
very interesting an important event I
also would like to welcome all of you
here on behalf of Aaron myself to what
promises to be a very interesting i
think it important evening i just want
to clarify one matter as I think you
mentioned a moment ago we invited some f
in here so many months ago but it's not
true that she's been planning ever since
to have a uprising throughout the Middle
Eastern North Africa as a result it's
that's a rumor I'd like to dispel so
there we are we're very very grateful to
her coming up from Washington today it's
enormously busy complicated and
interesting at the white house at the
moment I'm for her to take the time to
come here and talk to all of us I think
is a really great tribute to columbia
into the School of International Affairs
so without further ado Samantha power
thank you so much it's great to be here
it's great to be out of Washington and
it's wonderful to see I look out and see
a lot of friendly faces which is also a
lovely side benefit to being in New York
and to being at Columbia and it's a
special honor to be delivering the
Donald and Vera blinken lecture I first
met Donald and Vera blinken when I was a
cub reporter in the Balkans being
mentored by Mort Abramowitz a friend of
the blink ins and I got to know Vera on
the board of the International Rescue
Committee and welcome George Rupp and
George Biddle are here from IRC I feel
like I know Don and Vera better than I
actually do because of all the time I
get to spend in the Situation Room at
the White House with their son Tony
blinken Vice President Biden's chief
foreign policy adviser and one of the
most important members of the Obama
foreign policy team there are no more
decent human beings in the world than
Tony blinken and I have it on good
authority that we have his parents to
thank so even though I don't leave the
office much in my current job it seemed
well worth making the trip up to New
York for the blinkin family and of
course for Columbia University where my
father Edmund Burke is currently I think
taking five classes a semester as a
lifelong learner so he's putting the
rest of us to shame in terms of the
amount of knowledge he's cramming in to
a short period of time I know a lot of
you have Libya on the mind many have
Libya on the mind I certainly Olivia on
the mind I'm not going to talk much
tonight about Libya President Obama is
giving a major address to the nation and
I learned long ago never to give a
speech on the same topic as one of the
greatest speech makers in the history of
the world I know many of you have have
questions about Libya and I assure you
that President Obama will answer most of
those questions tonight now I will touch
upon it but
will not be my focus instead I will
spend my time with you describing
President Obama's broader approach to
the promotion and protection of human
rights and democracy and approach that
is deeply rooted in today's global
context so before i get into the human
rights and democracy approach i think
it's worth recalling the the world that
the president inherited in january 2009
when he when he took office it had a
number of striking features first the
transnational challenges that we face
face and face required the enlistment of
other countries in the solution whether
terrorism climate change
nonproliferation the refugee flows and
other humanitarian calamities that exist
or even just the need to maintain in
bolster the 40-plus multinational
contributions to the war in afghanistan
virtually every problem that one looked
at internationally was going to require
stepped-up international cooperation and
burden-sharing second feature of course
was a global recession and extremely
high unemployment at home there were a
huge number of foreign policy high
stakes foreign policy challenges that
awaited this administration this
president an unstable situation in Iraq
as we drew down our forces and as the
democratic experiment they're stabilized
the war in Afghanistan growing violence
and extremism in Pakistan Iran's attempt
to acquire a nuclear weapon and it's
brutal stifling of democratic the
Democratic will of its people tensions
on the Korean Peninsula which have only
grown more pronounced etc moreover part
of this global growing this global
context was that a growing share of the
global GDP and growing political
assertiveness was being exercised by
emerging powers emerging democracies but
also
countries like China and in terms of
Human Rights promotion and protection
specifically i would add two points to
this context first that the language of
human rights and democracy had been tied
up and associated with the war in Iraq
and other post 9-11 issues and the the
fight against terrorism around the world
in addition the so-called responsibility
to protect norm had emerged and indeed
have been embraced by the UN General
Assembly in 2005 but there were a few
takers in terms of enforcement of that
Norm it was one thing to state or
responsibly to protect another thing to
exercise it so that's just the backdrop
just bringing people back 22 january
2009 which feels a long way away many
much of what I've described of course is
still very much with us today but that
global context I think is important by
way of prelude to the approach that the
president has taken on human rights and
democracy in particularly so that
approach I would would structure in the
following way first the president set
out of course to restore American
standing in the world and he has spent
the last two years laying out a human
rights framework and elaborating on how
he and his administration see human
rights and democracy in the 21st century
and he has used his pulpit and a number
of speeches which I will refer to to
kind of clear the brush that had
gathered around the norms in previous
years rehabilitating some of the
principles and clearing up old
associations this I think has had two
effects first the words democracy and
human rights have come to acquire
meaning and content that Barack Obama
and his administration provided these
are kind of amorphous terms and people
project onto them all kinds of meaning
and I think the fact that he has set out
again to to fill out that content
himself has offered some clarity second
I think he
success in rehabilitating these norms or
providing that content has actually made
it easier for other governments to stand
with us not just on human rights issues
but on other issues as well and I'll
come to that later when I talk about
emerging democracies so what is this
clearing of the brush and reinvigorating
of these norms what exactly are we
talking about well the president has
argued consistently that our values and
our interests can't be easily separated
in his Nobel address he said there has
long been a tension between those who
describe themselves as realest or
idealist attention that suggests a stark
choice between the narrow pursuit of
interests or an endless campaign to
impose our values around the world I
reject these choices he said and this is
a theme that he will strike as well
tonight in his Libya address to the
nation as he presses for human rights
and democracy and political reform he
has long made a pragmatic case to other
peoples and other governments around the
world stressing governments that protect
these rights are ultimately more stable
more successful and more secure he's
also made that pragmatic case to
domestic audiences saying quote those
who defend these values for their people
have been our closest friends and allies
while those who have denied those rights
whether terrorist groups or tyrannical
governments have chosen to be our
adversaries so that there is a
correlation between the places where
reform and rights take hold and the
advancement of our interests and the
advancement of our peace and security
now his first tool in again sort of
setting out his own path on democracy
and human rights was recognizing that
human rights had to begin at home and
and that his first task and the
administration's first task was to try
to strengthen the power of our example
as he puts it our own struggle to
perfect our union here of course he set
out to ban torture to return to the
Geneva Conventions and
and to close Guantanamo which of course
has proven very challenging he also
renounced the imposition of democracy by
military forces again I think is an
important part of the the clearing of
the brush that went on there was an
association because of the war in Iraq
between the word democracy the notion of
democracy promotion and the Iraq
invasion he said in the Cairo speech
memorably no system of government can or
should be imposed by one nation by any
other and he also broke I think
important ground by saying by pledging
to respect the results of elections
provided they are peaceful and the
winners govern with respect for all
their people so a willingness to engage
with governments even those with whom we
disagree so that's first thing is that
it's sort of a clearing of the brush
rooted in our own practices and and our
own relationship to democracy and human
rights but another part of this
reinvigoration i think has been
insisting on a more inclusive conception
of what human rights and democracy
promotion entails and here I would I
would start by pointing to the emphasis
that the president consistently places
on the centrality of human dignity this
is something that he feels very very
strongly about and he has spoken about
dignity in the context of the dignity of
work and the dignity of opportunity the
dignity of peaceful protests and the
right to be able to assemble freely and
raise your voice and of course the
dignity inherent in being able to vote
for one's own leaders I think curious
twist on dignity is that he has spoken
not only in terms of individual dignity
but also in terms of the need to show
respect to cultures and nations and so
what kind of respect also for the
dignity of nations and for communities
began famous phrase mutual interest
mutual respect he's made clear that
democracy is
more than elections rule of law
independent media judiciary vibrant
private sector and civil society he has
stressed institutions and the need for
strong institutional foundations in the
gaana speech of course saying Africa
doesn't need strong men it needs strong
institutions and I think one of the the
most interesting uses of President
President Kennedy's many great quotes
who came in the Nobel address when the
president referred back to Kennedy's
line let us focus on a more practical
more attainable piece based not on a
sudden revolution in human nature but on
a gradual evolution in human
institutions so figuring out again how
to strengthen those institutions even if
that's going to mean evolution rather
than revolution in human affairs and of
course the president has emphasized the
link between freedom from fear and
freedom from want the to Roosevelt II
and ideas giving a greater emphasis to
economic development in foreign policy
than I think we've seen in generations
we have of course in in Tunisia and seen
a revolution sparked by the economic
frustrations of a fruit vendor and and
and thus see just how true it is the
connections between economic suffering
and and economic struggles on the one
hand and political repression and a need
for outlets to advance your economic and
political destiny Secretary Clinton in
this domain spearheaded the introduction
of a brand new tool to discipline the
government and to ensure that
development economic development get the
attention gets the attention that it
deserves we had long the US government
had long set priorities and something
known as the quadrennial defense review
or QDR but she introduced the QDDR which
is the quadrennial diplomacy and
development review and again the
president here has has been very clear
on the the inter linkage between
economic security and opportunity on the
one hand and civil and political rights
on the other additionally in terms of
this more thicker conception
of human rights and democracy the
president I think has spoken from his
own experience that of his family's
family around the world and with an eye
to the experience of millions living in
the developing world with his insistence
that corruption is in fact a profound
assault on human dignity and indeed a
human rights violation in and of itself
Secretary Clinton has highlighted
corruption for the first time
systematically in the annual us human
rights reports which had you know tended
to focus mainly on civil and political
abuses and and that again i think is
related to an emphasis on economic
opportunity but also an understanding
that your dignity is so violated when
somebody stops you and it's such a you
know ask for a bribe it's such a
fundamentally coercive act in such an
impediment to political as well as
economic development so finally in this
brush clearing exercise the president
has of course and you've heard a lot of
this lately has stressed that change
lasting change sustainable change is
bottom-up and indigenous most of his and
the Secretary's statements on events in
the Middle East stressed this point a
belief that the United States isn't
going to dictate you know the way
history turns in these societies that
what makes what we have seen on
television so inspiring in many respects
is the degree to which people are
claiming their own destiny nor of course
does this administration believe that
there's one model for change as the
president said back in Cairo each nation
gives life to the principle of democracy
in its own way grounded in the
traditions of its own people America
does not presume to know what is best
for everyone and then at the UN General
Assembly his first address he said each
country will pursue a path rooted in the
culture of its people and in its past
traditions now again this deference to
bottom-up change into indigenous
movements and the importance of
sustainability and so forth is not a
recipe for the United States you know
on the sideline are being indifferent to
human rights and democracy and and the
president has long coupled I think this
respect for other traditions with a
challenge to developing countries to
take responsibility to fix homegrown
problems with a degree of bluntness that
one doesn't always see in in public
addresses in other people's countries he
said in the Ghana speech the West is not
responsible for the destruction of his
in Bob Wian economy or wars in which
children are enlisted as combatants no
business wants to invest in a place
where the government schemes twenty
percent off the top and for just as it
is important to emerge from the control
of other nations colonialism the d
colonial pride that people post colonial
pride that people feel it is even more
important to build one's own nation so
it's very much an emphasis on
responsibility bottom-up change and and
and the need to not to scapegoat but to
take ownership of one's own community in
society and at all times amid this
deference and respect for four different
traditions the president has in the
secretary and the administration have
come back time and again to their
confidence though in the universality of
Human Rights that not only do the
international instruments you know speak
to that universality in terms of how
many countries and peoples have embraced
those instruments those norms but just a
deep belief that all people just share
certain things in common certain
yearnings in common and that they yearn
for for certain things and those things
are not Western values it's not Western
values that would cause the people of
Libya to risk their lives on the street
they are not the these values or not the
monopoly of one country as the president
said in Moscow and wherever possible I
think you see the President the
Secretary kind of grounding
reference to human rights and democratic
principles in the universal declaration
of human rights in the International
Covenant civil and political rights in
the Geneva Conventions and so forth
recognizing that these are not us sort
of projecting our values but that
they're that again in a bottom-up way
over a period of time these are values
that have been expressed in all
countries at all times so this is I
think just the framing for I forget what
the title of the speech is something
like Obama human rights and and no I
remember the rest of the speech for just
not the title Obama human rights and and
the new diplomacy this is kind of I
think at least tries to capture his
worldview he captures his worldview in
this string of speeches and I think
there's a freshness to a lot of what
I've described and I think it has
resonated in in corners of the world
that that had had become skeptical over
time and remains skeptical in certain
respects but that there this emphasis on
dignity the emphasis on justice as well
the invocation of universal rights the
respect for other traditions and for the
kind of ziggy-zaggy journeys that others
will will go on the the reckoning with
the USA's own practices and so forth and
the attempt to get our own house in
order and strive for a more perfect
union I think there has been real
resonance in these messages but what is
the new diplomacy then what what are the
diplomatic and and policy implications
of the framework that that I've
described well one place to start would
be the president's UN address of just
last September where he laid out an
agenda around open economies open
society and open government and and I
will say a little about each of these
things because each has policy
implications but but one of the things
that's very striking about this
framework is it's an attempt to find a
new point of entry to find a fresh way
at a conversation where people a lot of
people around the world have their minds
made up there's a fair amount of
polarization in the international system
around human rights and democracy and so
to come at this debate from the
standpoint of open and closed and to
supplement the broader human rights and
democracy conversation I think was an
interesting step forward open economies
you know within the international
community there had been long been
regional group solidarity creating a
false division really between civil and
political rights and basic freedom on
the one hand and social and economic
welfare on the other as I've mentioned
already in describing the president and
secretary and the whole system's
attention to development I think that
that emphasis has has helped bust
through that division but but but again
the administration has emphasized the
connection between open economies and
political freedom stressing for instance
in the Middle East how limited the
economic changes that will come about
will be without the kind of political
decentralization that's that's required
the argument is often made in the other
direction that is also true that of
course you know if you're starving
having a perfect Constitution isn't
going to get you very far but very
important to recognize the impact of
political decentralization and political
empowerment on economic development open
government is also I think a fresh and
and important concept of course began
with the president's own domestic open
government initiative the publishing of
the White House visitor logs the you
know giving greater transparency to the
assets of government officials etc
attempts to speed the processing of
freedom information requests and other
things and the internationally I think
this recognition of the link between
transparency on the one hand
accountability on the other better
governance than flowing from
transparency and
ability has led to some some I think
very compelling initiatives in this
space in order to strengthen
international norms against corruption
and improve governance this
administration has worked within the UN
the g20 the OECD and the international
financial institutions to promote the
recognition that corruption is a
violation of basic human rights and a
severe impediment to development and to
national security again often corruption
at least a generation ago was seen as a
as an impediment to us getting the most
bang for our buck in terms of
international assistance but to frame it
as something that's relevant again for
individuals around the world I think
it's very important and as something
that has to be mitigated before you're
going to see kind of lasting change in
institutional development so we've
worked with governments and with civil
society organisations to bring greater
transparency to government budgets to
expenditures and to the assets of public
officials we are trying to
institutionalize transparent practices
in the international aid flows also not
only for the taxpayers to see where US
assistance is going but also so the
recipient countries and peoples are able
to track that similar transparent
practices around banking and tax policy
and private sector engagement around
natural resources to make it harder for
officials to steal and and make a little
bit easier for citizens to hold their
governments accountable in terms of
natural resource flows we are seeking to
enlist emerging powers who again I'll
talk about in just a minute at greater
length but here you see countries like
India Indonesia Brazil South Africa
really Mexico doing tremendously
interesting work in harnessing new
technologies to promote better
governance to bring citizens into the
conversation into a more collaborative
relationship with government or even
more adversarial relationship with
government but transparency being you
this new technology being used to
strengthen that connection and again
improve performance the third dimension
of the youngest beach was open society
and here Secretary Clinton in particular
has been very much out in front of the
effort to strengthen civil society
around the world the administration has
practiced I think pretty consistently
again across departments and agencies
what we like to think of as dual track
engagement normally dual track means you
know you do well you know with dual
track means but one version of dual
track is not only that officials meet
other officials but that civil society
meet civil society and our officials
when we go abroad don't just meet with
people who wear badges around their
necks but also seek out citizens and
organizations and bloggers who are often
not in the most collaborative
relationship with those governments and
indeed who in some cases are the people
who have just been locked up by the
government's but this kind of standing
guidance that you've got to get out
beyond status circles I think is an
important defining new dimension of
secretary Clinton's leadership at the
State Department and it's permeated
across the board secretary gates when he
was in Egypt last week had a meeting
with a group of civil society activists
and you're seeing more and more those
kinds of meetings occurring and their
themselves of course a window into
feedback on or their themselves a route
to receiving feedback on u.s. foreign
policies and and and on our performance
in these countries Secretary Clinton has
also launched a new fund to provide
legal representation to human rights
defenders who are unjustly imprisoned
for doing nothing more than speaking up
for the rights of their fellow citizens
working within the Human Rights Council
at the UN in Geneva we were able last
year to join with several untraditional
partners who we had you know
traditionally sort of struggle to team
up with in international institutions to
respond to a
pretty distinct and disturbing moment in
time which was a spike in crackdown on
civil society around the world a real
shrinking of the space in which
journalists and nongovernmental
organizations were able to do their
business and taking you know note of
this moment we joined with these other
countries to create the first ever
international mechanism to monitor the
crackdown on civil society basically to
track it country by country and this is
a new Special Rapporteur for freedom of
association freedom of assembly one of
Secretary Clinton signature initiatives
which I'm sure many of you know about is
of course promoting Internet freedom
recognizing that one of the most potent
enabling rights is the right to connect
and the right to access information was
just thinking as I was flying up here
just that the global outrage over
Egypt's shutting off of the internet
which now feels like it was some time
back in the 1970s uh-huh but when they
shut down the internet the the outrage
around the world just the idea that you
could have an on/off switch and and shut
it on off obviously other governments
are sophisticated in their ability to
censor and to sigh me internet use but
something is dramatic is that and then
the global again sort of revolt against
that shut down I think indicates to some
extent just how potent this kind of
right to connect norm has become in a
very short period of time and obviously
we recognizing that new technologies are
fueling people-powered movements around
the world and shining a spotlight on
human rights abuses allowing people to
upload what's happening in their
neighborhoods you know in some of these
very challenging environments today you
know we are channeling programs and
trying to support the dissemination of
technologies to facilitate this free
expression and to expand access to
information increase the transparency
and counter the many many restrictions
that are developing on use
so this is the kind of the new point of
entry or a new point of entry is to go
at this through an open government lens
through an open society and lens through
an open economy lens having laid out
that broad set of principles and that
and that and filled out the meaning of
the traditional human rights and
democracy language the third thing that
this administration has done with the
president's leadership is invested in
the multilateral system generally and
the human rights architecture
specifically President Obama has said in
an era when our destiny is shared power
is no longer a zero-sum game and we see
we see this at work in a range of
policies across a range of issue areas
from non-pro to peacekeeping to
counterterrorism etc but when he when
the president launched his so-called era
of engagement he was seeking to invest
in an international system so that the
system itself would do a better job of
delivering global public goods and so
that there could be more burden-sharing
so that we in the United States could
rebalance more and and and tend to the
home front where there are so many needs
now there are many examples of the sort
of exercise of the decision to engage
the international system in a new way in
a very aggressive way but those
engagements that touch upon democracy
and human rights the subject of this
talk include the decision to engage the
flawed human rights council which I'll
speak about to engage the alliance of
civilizations as an observer and
re-energize the Community of Democracies
which would which is not yet reached its
promise I just like to say a few words
about the Human Rights Council which is
kind of became the poster child for what
was wrong with the UN system and wrong
with the way that human rights were
promoted in particular in the UN system
the council of course has long given
disproportionate attention to Israel
while sliding human rights abuses in
power
awful countries like China and in
addition its proceedings for any of you
have ever had to witness them have often
seemed divorced from the suffering of
the real world it wasn't very nimble and
bad things were happening in the world
that very the kind of old debates from
10 or 20 years ago were resurrected and
impeded even holding special sessions or
drawing attention to abuses that were
ongoing and we knew all about all of
these flaws and we think we're quite
clear I'd back in 2009 about how much
work it would take to really change the
council and ensure it worked better for
for real people but President Obama
Secretary Clinton ambassador rice and
others felt strongly that it was we'd be
far better off trying to fix the Human
Rights Council from within in addition
we didn't really have the luxury of just
writing off the UN's main Human Rights
body and I think they anticipated also
that just the active engagement and this
is something that's kind of inchoate and
hard to quantify but actually just being
seen to engage in good faith and to sit
down with others and roll up your
sleeves and try to find in consensus
path forward actually creates a kind of
some amount of goodwill that we can draw
upon in other settings and we've really
seen that ambassador rice has it long
described the sort of spillover effect
from Geneva to New York and vice versa
frankly because of the way she engages
here so these would this was the sort of
logic of engagement was the era of
engagement meeting the era of
responsibility as the president like to
say and and here we are a couple years
into our tenure there and while the
flaws that I have mentioned still remain
and one you know cannot sugarcoat what
goes on in Geneva the doubt that the
downside of what goes on in Geneva I
will say that we have just completed
what I think is the most successful one
month stint in the Human Rights councils
history arguably even in the history of
the Human Rights Commission that proceed
did and I'll just run through a few of
the things that we've managed to do with
our partners in Geneva some of which you
you actually read about the proceedings
the Human Rights Council don't normally
make headlines but because of the Libya
events the council has been more in the
news than usual together with a broad
across regional set of partners we
succeeded in creating a special
repertory to monitor human rights abuses
in Iran now this is again doesn't sound
like that big a deal perhaps but it's
the first-ever country-specific special
repertory created by the council and the
reason that those country specific
positions are so hard to create is that
in the developing world countries feel
very strongly that we shouldn't single
countries out that that's an
interference and internal affairs and in
sovereignty and so forth now Iran's
crackdown and so forth made our argument
easier to make in this context but I
also think that some of those habits and
some of those divisions that have
paralyzed the council are breaking down
a little bit as people recognize you
know outside Western circles that you
have to call spade a spade if human
rights abuses are occurring and and and
and a vote comes up you have to take a
stand one way the other we just Friday
created a commission of inquiry for
ivory coast where there has been a
really worrying spike in violence the
last two months of course you have two
claimants for the presidency one who was
democratically elected and the other who
lost and who's holding on to power so
the creation of commission of inquiry at
least creates the specter of
accountability as the individuals around
those two leaders you know increasingly
are prone to take violent measures in
order to achieve their political destiny
and we're of course trying to tighten
the screws diplomatically in the
commission of inquiry I think is a part
of that you know showing that there will
be a price to be paid both in terms of
stealing an election and in terms of any
of the violent acts that would be
carried out in
before the political situation is
resolved now for Libya as I mentioned we
we also created a commission of inquiry
to some extent that achievement was
overtaken then by word that the UN
Security Council had referred the crimes
in Libya to the International Criminal
Court but again what made Libya quite
extraordinary is the council came
together held a special session an
emergency session where you need some
number of signatures in order to get an
emergency session on the books again
those are few and far between and made
the decision both to create this
commission of inquiry in advance of the
ICC referral and as you know to expel
for the first time in the history of the
human rights council one of its members
namely Libya Human Rights Council made
that decision then the decision was
passed on to the General Assembly which
the following week did indeed decide to
suspend Libya's membership so this again
you know this is the Human Rights
Council a venue that we're using more
and more to do traditional business I
mean this advanced the u.s. is foreign
policy aims in the moment it wasn't it
isn't just a small sort of boutique
location where human rights concerns are
raised and and and rejected it's a place
where we were able to use some of what
the council offered as a way of
compounding the Qaddafi regime is
diplomatic isolation in the early days
of this crisis so thanks to American
leadership and I think some encouraging
signs from regional leaders in Latin
America Africa and Asia we're starting
to see the council do real foreign
policy business and and real work on
behalf of human rights I don't want to
overstate the progress it is steady I
believe but it is also slow and and we
have a lot of work to do but there's no
question that the president's decision
to seek membership I think has been
redeemed by the ways in which we've been
able to use it as a tool for human
rights promotion and protection and a
broader tool I think to signal to the
rest of the international community that
we're back that we do want to roll up
our sleeves that we do want to try to
build bridges even on some of the most
hence and polarizing issues in the
international system now the general
attitude toward the United Nations to
tour the United States in the United
Nations has warmed of course in the last
couple years there's a much more
congenial not perfect we don't get
descript everything but a more congenial
negotiating environment than the one
that we inherited in early 2009 I'll
just give you one statistic that I think
is quite telling in 2008 the United
States was the only no vote on more than
thirty percent of the resolutions that
came before the UN General Assembly in
2009 we were in this position only a
single time so from thirty percent to
just a single vote and in 2010 there
wasn't a single instance in which the
u.s. voted no in isolation on a
resolution now this represents sometimes
a change in the u.s. position but more
than that it represents a willingness to
get in and try to shape the text of
these resolutions before they come to a
vote or frankly to get other countries
to join us in opposing resolutions we
don't like but i think it was noteworthy
that 2009 saw the largest one year shift
in voting coincidence with the united
states since voting began back in 1946
and that pattern has continued into this
year so that's the kind of multilateral
approach a recognition that it's
multilateralism is not a luxury in a
world with all these transnational
challenges and in a world where our
military and our diplomatic capital and
our financial capital is very
overstretched but it's a necessity and
it requires systemic investments and not
just a la carte investments in the
multilateral system the fourth dimension
of the president's approach to human
rights protection and promotion is the
enlistment of emerging democracies in
the cause of human rights promotion and
when President Obama took office the
number of democracies in the world had
grown in the previous two decades from
in 1989 to 119 in 2009 however the
number of countries talking about and
supporting democracy and human rights
bilaterally and in these international
fora had remained quite static the same
kind of faces the same group of
countries we're still pressing the human
rights cause in part because again the
polarization of the debate that I've
already referred to we have made a
concerted effort to try to get to try to
work with emerging democracies and to
bring them into the business of human
rights promotion and protection most of
the trips that president obama has
chosen to take in his first two years
highlight the role for an embrace of
emerging democracies and with regional
democratic anchors so some of the
countries he visit of course Ghana India
Indonesia Japan Korea Brazil Chile I
mean these are he's seeking to highlight
the values that are enjoyed at home and
seeking to use these trips in order to
to bring these bilateral partnerships
into more meaningful joint regional and
multilateral action specifically he's
appealed to those countries that have
really stepped up in the g20 to take on
more economic responsibilities now to
also take on enhanced political
responsibilities in the international
system with you know trying to encourage
a greater willingness to step up to
contest threats to international peace
and security and of course to stand up
for those who were suffering human
rights abuses one of the most memorable
I think sort of illustrations of this
effort on the president's part came
again in his UN General Assembly speech
where he drew very deliberate attention
to the kind of disconnect between the
values that some emerging democracies
that emerging democracies by definition
enjoy at home but that some of them were
not injecting fully into their foreign
policies and he issued an appeal he said
I appeal to those nations who emerged
from tyranny and inspired the world in
second half of the last century from
South Africa to South Asia from Eastern
Europe to South America don't stand idly
by don't be silent when dissidents
elsewhere are imprisoned and protesters
are beaten recall your own history and
then this is my favorite line because
part of the price of our own freedom is
standing up for the freedom of others
and this was you know in front of the
heads of state from many of the
countries where this disconnect has been
has been evident in our work together on
the Human Rights Council Indonesia South
Africa and Brazil have expressed
skepticism that I referred to earlier
about country specific human rights
promotion policies so what we've done is
is worked with them partnered with them
first on more general global human
rights concerns such as the special
repertoire I mentioned for freedom of
association assembly the create we
created together a new mechanism to
combat discrimination against women and
a i think a groundbreaking
cross-regional statement calling for the
end to violence against LGBT persons and
this just happened actually last week in
the same Human Rights Council session
shouldn't be radical to get a statement
like that but to get 85 countries in the
international system to sign on to an
LGBT statement is significant and I
think again a move in the right
direction we have also saw it again in
the spirit of bringing these emerging
democracies on board to enlist them or
two or to seek them out early in the
process rather than kind of having
something that we want something we want
their support for then kind of jamming
them at the ends or basic diplomacy I
guess but they had the sense that they
were often an afterthought and and we
are really seeking to come up with ideas
with them about about how we can
collaborate and the only way that you
kind of get some of the progress that
I've described modest though it may seem
is by engaging not just in the
international institution itself not in
the multilateral fora but at a very high
level in capitals so making sure that
you know very senior officials whether
the President the Secretary the Vice
President are calling and trying to
close the deal and and and secure the
cooperation
and it matters we also engage them and I
think this is important and easy to
forget recognizing that we are not the
only ones who have domestic politics to
contend with over over time I think that
the government's in emerging democracies
are far more likely to inject human
rights concerns into their foreign
policy when they are held accountable
domestically for ignoring human rights
abuses and and this is sort of a basic
statement the obvious about foreign
policy accountability but many of these
countries are still consolidating their
Democratic gains and the the checks and
balances domestically aren't yet
necessarily as focused on foreign policy
and it's worth recalling that in the
United States several decades ago it was
the Congress that pushed the executive
branch to consider human rights and
began restricting funding streams on
human rights grounds it was us civil
society and us constituents who remains
in fact us civil society and us
constituents who hold all of us in
government accountable not just for our
policies at home but but for our actions
abroad and similarly in these new
democracies we recognize that it's going
to take time for parliament civil
society and media to turn outward we
have some seen some interesting examples
though for instance the Burma caucus in
Indonesia's parliament has played an
important role putting the fate of
Burmese on the political map in
Indonesia and they've shown I think some
interesting leadership within ASEAN
we've seen Brazilian a bottom-up
letter-writing campaign from Brazilian
citizens to press Brazilian the previous
Brazilian President Lula to offer asylum
to the Iranian woman who'd been
sentenced to be stoned to death we've
seen countless campaigns of course by
investigative journalists bloggers
facebook users pressing human rights
causes at home in these democracies and
it just does seem like it's only a
matter of time where you're going to
start to see those same tools used to
impose the kind of accountability again
that we live with cheerfully every day
in this country
in Indonesia which has 13,000
nongovernmental organizations in in the
spirit of trying to encourage this
outward orientation the United States
has launched a new initiative pledging
to fund those groups those local
domestic groups who are interested in
working in the region interested in
taking what they've learned through
going through this journey from
dictatorship to democracy you know if
they have insights and best practices
that they want to share with their with
their regional colleagues so I think
getting the emerging democracies
ensuring that the coalition of countries
who are promoting democracy and human
rights is a broader coalition is
incredibly important fifth and finally
the president has in in terms of his
overall approach to human rights policy
he has made an unprecedented commitment
to preventing mass atrocity and again
he's going to be speaking to this
tonight but Libya is is the most
high-profile case in which this
administration has opened up its toolbox
and deployed a range of diplomatic
economic and judicial accountability and
commission of inquiry and other tools
and of course when it was clear that 10
days ago or whenever was that those
tools would not be enough to prevent the
fall of Benghazi a town of 700,000
people the president mobilized an
international coalition on behalf of
military measures to protect civilians
to put the Libyan events in some
historical context that's kind of you
know one thing about having written
about about mass atrocities is to is to
see what this administration has done
and and then put it in this historical
context it took more than a year for the
international community to impose asset
freezes on those responsible for
violence against civilians in Bosnia and
actually two years to impose travel bans
on those individuals who were involved
in violence against civilians in Libya
it took us nine days to impose asset
freezes and travel bans in the Balkans
took three years of course for the
international community to intervene
with air power to stop heavy weaponry
firing on civilians and prevent further
atrocities and in Libya it took a little
more than a month but this commitment by
President Obama to this goal is not new
even in his Cairo address it's this part
of the Cairo dress I hadn't actually
even remembered until I went back and
read it recently but he generated fierce
applause when he challenged countries in
the Muslim world to recognize that the
slaughter of innocence was a what he
called a stain on our collective
conscience and there he referred to
Darfur in Bosnia in his Nobel speech
back in in december two thousand nine he
said in many ways foreshadowing I think
the speech that he will give tonight
quote I believe that force can be
justified on humanitarian grounds as it
was in the Balkan Balkans inaction tears
at our conscience and can lead to more
costly intervention later that's why all
responsible nations must embrace the
role that militaries with a clear
mandate can play to keep the peace and
quote he has also taken a number of
concrete steps inside the bureaucracy
which may be of interest only to me in
this room but those steps actually make
it more likely that we can prevent
atrocities before they escalate to a
scale as they did in Libya he
established with little fanfare the
first-ever White House position
dedicated exclusively to coordinating
policies on preventing identifying and
responding to mass atrocities and
genocide the president recognized that
the task of preventing genocide was an
achievable goal but one that would
require governmental organization and
engagement that resembled the intensity
and efficiency of those who were intent
on carrying out mass killings so at the
National Security Council we have this
new position and it's made a world of
difference we have a new director no
longer new now there for more than a
year but an NSC director for war crimes
and
rasa tease he's definitely the worst
title job title in government and I've
had the privilege of being with him when
he hands his business card to foreign
leaders which is even more fun but this
individual is his name David Pressman
spends his days looking for early
indicators of potential atrocities
developing high-level political
strategies to respond to those
indicators and he helps coordinate the
enlistment of international partners in
this effort and one of the things we're
hoping to mobilize is the appointment in
other governments of similar sort of
points of contact or similar individuals
where you can have a kind of quasi red
phone between individuals who are really
looking at the early warning signs of
mass atrocities but from the NSC which
is the coordinating mechanism for the
government it's his his his presence has
made a world of difference bringing the
intelligence community the Treasury
Department the Justice Department the
State Department the Defense
Department's that are together to make
sure that we're using mainly
non-military tools in in virtually all
cases in order to deter atrocities again
before they escalate in January thanks
largely to the intensity and fervor of
US leadership the people of southern
Sudan were able to vote for independence
in relative peace and we are now working
to try to prevent violence and atrocity
in advance of that southern Sudan's
expected independence this summer on
Darfur of course we haven't yet seen the
progress we seek but i can tell you
personally it's not for lack of trying
and we continue to hold the sudanese
government accountable for its attacks
on civilians and to invest substantial
diplomatic and other resources in
pursuing a piece that could allow the
people of Darfur to live with the same
basic rights and dignity as their
neighbors in southern Sudan we believe
that this too is an achievable goal if a
very challenging one in conclusion
President Obama has set the United
States on a new course taking account of
an altered global context he has
restored us standing
replenished the US commitment and filled
out the US commitment to human rights
norms given meaning to what he and his
team mean by human rights and democracy
promotion he has embraced a series of
policies aimed at promoting open
economies open society and open
government he's invested in the
multilateral system recognizing that
especially when you're acting or
speaking out on behalf of universal
human rights principles you'll be more
effective the more universal your
coalition is so the broader the more
countries you have by your side the less
daylight there is in the international
system and the less of a likelihood that
a country committing human rights abuses
can play countries in the international
system off against one another in that
spirit he has worked to enlist emerging
democracies who we feel are natural
allies in the long term on these efforts
and he has sought to prevent mass
atrocities that would eclipse progress
in other human rights areas and stain
our collective conscience we obviously
have a long way to go in the cause of
human rights promotion and protection
but the president Secretary Clinton and
the rest of his cabinet I think have
charted a course that we were confident
will over time help bend the famous arc
of history toward justice thank
we we have the opportunity to take some
questions which I will be moderating and
they are written questions that is not
uncommon practice when we're dealing
with public officials so it's my
understanding that paper has been
distributed and questions have been
raised and I guess what I'm going to
start with a one thing we do this should
should i maybe anyway let me start with
one but rather which is where do you
draw the line is where and when to
intervene when protesters are being
killed or threatened is it just a matter
of sure numbers and again what is the
magic number that unleash r2p 1010
10,000 100,000 or is it the ease of a
clean quotes for Westerners military
mission no Western casualties as opposed
to say to another Mogadishu okay that
should go ahead hit that well i think
that the one of the things that's
important to do is is is is define again
the sort of idea of intervention which
in libya began with diplomatic economic
judicial arms embargo you know the whole
series of tools that you know again in
Prior cases are lament in many instances
was not that the United States should
have sent military force into another
country to try to stop atrocities but
the lament was we didn't do the little
things we didn't do the diplomat didn't
take the diplomatic steps didn't
denounce didn't make calls at a high
level didn't expel ambassadors didn't
tighten the diplomatic noose didn't try
to locate
and freeze foreign assets didn't do
radio jamming didn't didn't didn't you
know those that was the story of the
prior cases so i think when there are
human rights abuses and certainly when
people are being killed whenever you
know one person is killed by a
government you know the US has a foreign
policy with with that country of some
form with a couple exceptions out there
we we have either an embassy on the
ground or we have some way of expressing
ourselves and taking a stand on human
rights abuses and and so on that
continuum of intervention from the soft
side to the much more robust and very
rare and needs to be very rare side
their whole series of steps I think that
can be taken so you know again it's not
a situation where there is a magic
number I think in the case of Benghazi
the track record that moammar qaddafi
had had amassed both over the last four
decades you know in which on a single
day he killed executed 1200 people
simply on suspicion of disloyalty and
the reports that we've gotten from the
towns that he's overrun and the
flattening of apartment buildings and
the denial of medical care and all the
rest and the special role that Benghazi
are the special importance of Benghazi
in the rebellion I think that the our
best judgment was that what would have
happened had that town been overrun
would have been extremely chilling
deadly and indeed again a stain on our
on our collective conscience so I think
what distinguished Libya was the fact
that there was an international mandate
a UN Security Council authorization
which President Obama feels was very
very important to have there was a
coalition including that included Arab
states from the region and some of our
closest NATO allies that were willing to
share the burden of attempting to
protect civilians and there was the
potential for such a horrific scale that
it meant that having tried other tools
in the toolbox and having seen events on
the ground kind of outpace those tools
the decision was made to move to the
more robust side of the spectrum but I
think it's very important to remember
and this is what we're doing in Ivory
Coast and what we did in Sudan in
advance of the referendum again with our
international partners to remember just
how many tools there are short of
military force and how much more
desirable it is to use those other tools
given the risks and the costs associated
with military force you spoke about open
economies and political freedoms can you
discuss I'm so sorry yes
pardon me here and yes this is from a
Columbia sepa school of international
Public Affairs student could you
speaking of economic open economies
excuse me in political freedoms can you
discuss the us-china relations sure just
like that you're a couple of others that
are more or less pointed but in that
direction okay okay should I leave now I
guess well I don't want to get into this
too much but I will just say that that
part of what we're doing every day is
trying to balance a whole number of
interests at once one of which is the
one that I spent 45 minutes talking
about which are the human rights
interests and I think you heard during
the summit when who Jintao visited the
United States just how prominent the
human rights concerns were in that visit
my friend my dear friends Laura and Emma
from Human Rights Watch are here today
ken Roth from Human Rights Watch was not
only present at the state dinner but we
seated him next to the Chinese
ambassador to Washington and we used
also the knowledge that the summit was
coming was on the horizon in order to
press the Chinese government to do more
on Sudan because it just as it happened
the referendum was on January ninth in
the summit was about a week later ten
days later so again using the fact of
the summit to draw greater attention to
the plight of political dissidents and
ordinary Chinese who are unjustly
incarcerated and also to to take note of
the importance of China stepping into a
very different kind of role in Sudan
where they haven't always been a
constructive player but we saw much more
outspokenness and much more leadership
from them on Sudan in a way that I think
made it actually a real difference so in
terms of the political freedom open
economy I mean with you know there's
geithner were here he could do the open
economies part of the answer but I think
what we've seen in the last few weeks is
is very very disturbing an already grim
human rights situation has deteriorated
as the Chinese government appears to be
fearful of the Arab Spring spreading and
some of the tools that have been used in
places that in and against regimes that
once seemed untouchable that those tools
would get used again so we're stepping
up our diplomacy on human rights grounds
and maintaining the security and the
economic and the other dialogues there
that are critical also for our national
interests a couple of questions well the
gist is presented here by Ben Smith from
Politico could you comment on the recent
reports of a boys versus girls rift
inside the administration didn't you say
there was a second question
well there it may be related okay that's
all right I will I will comment only to
say that that the stories are completely
inaccurate utterly untrue distorted
unhelpful bad reporting that's good
hello this is a question posed by a
graduate student at Columbia has Obama
considered or what he ever consider
using the language of human rights to
advance his domestic agenda for example
around healthcare it's a good question I
my others like Ben who covered the
campaign may have a better memory of
this than I on the domestic side but but
my man or my parents who are physicians
but my memory is that the president has
in fact used the human rights framework
and talked about a right to healthcare
and indeed that that was one of the
framing sort of the approaches that he
took in a campaign and Beyond
culminating in this historic legislative
achievement so my sense is that he is
has has done that and this is that I
could lead you out or more on questions
of the significance of women's rights
and their protection for American
foreign policy and international
humanitarian strategy a couple questions
that are no it's a great question in
trying to remember now when it was about
a year ago Secretary Clinton went up to
the UN Security Council and made a
pledge that we would pull together a
national action plan on women peace and
security and we're very much in the
thick of preparing that means bringing
again all the different agencies and
departments together around that
that cause it means thinking about you
know famously mainstreaming you know
women's protection issues and so forth
but also changing the way we are
structured as a government to ensure
that we're responsive and that we
undertake kind of prophylactic measures
as well I mentioned in the atrocity and
and and genocide context the difference
that having just a single individual
working with me at the White House has
made in our ability to do atrocity
prevention I mean it's it's it's really
really significant just again a small
investment of human capital so to at the
State Department the fact that we have
melanne verveer you know as the
designated individual who's in every
meeting and she's a wonderfully forceful
personality and such vast knowledge so
in the policy process she's in every
meeting pressing to get these issues on
the agenda she's traveling globally to
convey us commitments in this regard I
may think again for both for the
president for the whole cabinet for
Admiral Mullen secretary Gates they've
all spoken about this so often but they
view women's empowerment as a matter for
national security you know that
ultimately when you have women who are
politically participating when they're
not under threat either to domestic
violence or to violent conflict
societies are more stable more secure
more successful all the things i
mentioned president mentioned earlier so
we're working on this National Action
Plan we're trying to bring the resources
together and we're and we're trying to
multilateral eyes the agenda including
getting of course UN peacekeepers to
take sexual violence violence against
women and children far more seriously a
question about why has there been no
about American administrators response
to the crackdown in Bahrain
and whether you would advise
intervention there again I just come
back to the same point from before which
is that intervention i think is an
unhelpful way of framing things because
it lumps together a phone call from our
DC mr you know deputy chief of mission
to a local Bahraini official on the one
hand that's an interim attic
intervention to you know the creation of
a no-fly zone in libya that's it that's
another form of intervention so i think
i think we have not been silent the
president secretary National Security
Advisor Tom Donilon have not been at all
silent about the crackdown in Bahrain
issuing very critical statements and
working tirelessly at all levels to try
to get a political dialogue restarted
which has become of course more
difficult the more the violence says has
taken hold but but it's an area of huge
focus again for the entire
administration and the fact that we have
our seventh Fleet Based in Bahrain
actually you know I think I mean has
given us even more avenues to be raising
the concerns that we have and to be
pressing for a political dialect
pressing both sides both the government
and the opposition okay there's some
questions that regard civil rights in
the US one that discussed to discuss the
questions around the Guantanamo closing
and how the administration is dealt with
that not below not that specifically
related about the civil rights of
American Muslims and how the
administration has been dealing with
attacks on their freedoms well I then
the third on the about the abuse of
Bradley Manning private Manning so all
three questions which are related to
domestic well I would just say on the on
the on the Guantanamo closing issue just
that again as the president said in his
signing statement of the National
Defense Authorization Act you know we
are you know still he is still intent on
finding a way to close Guantanamo it's
it's the domestic climate is very very
difficult of course on that issue and
it's you know we there have been now
restrictions that are imposed that are
making it very challenging to follow
through on the plans that were made but
as you heard again a few weeks ago when
we rolled out the new executive order
and when military commissions were being
restarted the commitment to article 3
trials remains every bit as strong as it
has always been for this president in
terms of Bradley Manning I would just
say again that we have full confidence
in in the Defense Department and in the
facilities and the protections that he's
being afforded in terms of the civil
rights of muslim-americans I think this
has been a huge priority at the White
House not just from the president but
also deputy national security advisor
Denis McDonough just gave a major
address on this issue he's worked very
closely with John Brennan the
president's counterterrorism advisor and
and again they're huge efforts to reach
out and to try to promote tolerance in
our own country recognizing as I said in
my remarks that that this struggle at
home in this quest for the more perfect
union is ultimately our most potent
weapon in promoting human rights and
protecting human rights abroad so I
would just refer you to Dennis the
speech which lists a range of
initiatives that this administration has
under
taken in this regard okay take a couple
more questions of what one has to do and
this came up in a couple of questions
about whether the administration is how
it's using economic development tools
effectively especially in Africa whether
the use has changed with respect to
previous administrations I mean I'm not
myself sort of present on the back end
of the policies but I know that the
prime emphasis is on so-called country
ownership and basically not having a
one-size-fits-all model developed in
Washington or develop for one country
and then applied to another country but
really trying to ensure that the
policies are granular and that there are
feedback mechanisms where citizens and
civil society can offer you know
constructive commentary on how US
programs are actually affecting real
people so I know that's the philosophy
of it I can't speak to to what actually
you know to particulars of country
situations you know last question coming
from a historian or a PhD candidate in
history what contribution did
humanitarian interventionist or
humanitarian intervention is it make to
the launching of the Iraq war in 2003
did humanitarian intervention ISM
unbalanced facilitate the war or deter
it well what I will say it again in my
current job I it's not necessarily by
reflecting on past historical events
it's not necessarily what I'm here to do
but what I can say I guess is just that
they make the obvious point that the
that the administration the Bush
administration gave a range of
justifications for going to war in Iraq
and I think two different individuals
within the administration at that time
were motivated by very different things
this is always the case and you know
you're you're surrounded by people who
come with very different perspectives
and backgrounds and and sometimes they
their policy motives diverge but their
policy judgments converge and an overlap
and so I think there were individuals in
the bush ministration who were very
motivated by the plight of Iraq's people
there were people who were motivated by
the weapons of mass destruction
allegations and so forth there were
people who were motivated by you know
911 and you know the the pretty fragile
sort of connect the dots to that but it
was it was something that motivated
individuals so you know I think that the
motives are varied and and the those
sort of strands came together and and
convince the president who I think was
probably motivated by all of the above
and more and I guess what I would say is
that once the war in Iraq started
because the welfare of Iraqis you know
quickly deteriorated it also took on I'm
in the US military and took on
heroically really the task of of trying
to protect Iraqis and and strengthen
security so they weren't as vulnerable
to attack so in that sense while I think
the the precipitant was not primarily
humanitarian may have been for again an
individual or were several individuals
but over time you know the the US
military had to become in a hurry
skilled at providing humanitarian
assistance once the international
agencies and the UN and others withdrew
after that some of the terrorist attacks
in late two thousand three and two
thousand four you know the the United
States took on some of those
humanitarian roles and honestly you know
has capabilities today that that it
didn't have back then but it's also of
course very overstretched by having and
many many families have done multiple
tours for having you know maintained a
presence in into to conflict areas over
time which again is one of the reasons
that the president is so mindful of the
costs and and and the downsides of
military action and so determined to
ensure that the scope of the Libya
action is limited in duration and that
we very quickly move to a support role
because there are many countries who in
NATO and beyond NATO who are willing to
take on this larger burden going forward
so why don't I leave it there thank you
all for coming